[Music]
good afternoon everybody happy Monday
okay I'm just gonna get is it Tuesday
Holy Cow happy Tuesday
oh my gosh Tom his time
all right it's Tuesday happy Tuesday
everybody
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's May 17 2023 we're live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals if you have
not joined us at
reubenreport.locals.com please do we got
a post game show you get Insider info
Advanced knowledge of things and more
and we've got an IOS and Android app so
check it out uh before we get to the
meat of the show today I just have to
say you know right before the show we
always always pull the guys how are we
going to do how are we going to do today
and my feeling is you know anything
above like a 9-5 anywhere from you know
nine five and a nine nine great show
great show I'd like to say that we're
mostly in that vicinity the 10 is almost
impossible Perfection I would say is
basically impossible so it's very rare
once I think we all finished up we were
like that's as close to perfect as
possible but I would still say it would
be like a 99999 the 10 is impossible you
know it would be like touching God it's
impossible right before we started today
Phoenix says to the guys well what are
we gonna do today Brock what do you
think Broncos 9-3 lowballed me so this
show
I'm doing in spite this is a spite show
for Brock I'm going to lay out a 9798
right now okay I promise you it's coming
and uh you're not getting lunch that's
how we're doing this today
what we're going to be talking about
today people is bravery because it's
important it's needed and I think
perhaps there is a Resurgence of it we
need some fearlessness we need some
people who are out there and willing to
say what they believe and fight for the
good things and return us to a degree of
normalcy it's happening on the ground
we're going to focus a lot of it on an
interview that Elon Musk did yesterday
with CNBC right after the Tesla
shareholder meeting I mean it's not just
that the guys running this freaking
Twitter thing he's running Tesla he's
running SpaceX and he's basically saying
whatever he wants about pretty much
everything which I think is the antidote
to almost all of our problems right now
and we must know as I often say guys the
people that we're fighting and we're
going to have evidence of it in today's
show they're not the brightest
that's number one number two they're
Liars okay so they're not bright and
they're liars and number three if you
just shine a little light on that I
think you can turn things around that is
our goal today nine seven to a nine nine
really if I gotta rethink this situation
uh let's talk about janucel real quick
and then we'll get to it you know gen
yacel's skin care is powered by the skin
nourishing of rare Botanical extracts
and in powerful antioxidants in a
proprietary skin care case to deliver
results you'll love guaranteed the
genucel therapy for under eye bags and
puffiness can visibly diminish
appearance of annoying bags and
puffiness right before your eyes do I
have any bags under my eyes no you see
right now save over 70 percent over at
genu cell using their most popular
package featuring their new Ultra
retinol with natural retinol alternative
and for a limited time get a
complimentary Spa Essentials box with
every package plus free priority
shipping go to geniusell.com
Dave and now back to me all right here
we go so let's start with this interview
One Clip we got a couple of them for you
first clip of Elon Musk who's running
Tesla running SpaceX around the Twitter
doing the neuro link a whole bunch of
other stuff busy guy fairly busy guy uh
who sat down to do a live interview on
CNBC immediately after
this Tesla shareholder meeting yesterday
which I believe was in Austin Texas
right that's where they are that's
probably where the meeting was uh and uh
the reporter was asking him hey you know
you're saying all this stuff all the
time are you are you worried about
saying all the stuff and saying what you
think that could be problematic
you know do your tweets hurt the company
are there Tesla owners to say I don't
agree with his political position
because and I know it because he shares
so much of it or their advertisers on
Twitter that Linda Ocarina will come and
say you gotta stop man or you know I
can't get these ads because of some of
the things you tweet
you know I'm reminded of
uh
there's a scene in The Princess Bride
great movie great um
where
he confronts the person who killed his
father
he says
offer me money
offer me power
I don't care
so you just don't care
you want to share what you have to say
I'll say what I want to say and if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it
okay okay so there's a couple
interesting things here first off that
he makes a Princess Bride reference just
in and of itself is pretty fantastic but
putting that aside for a second first
off really think about it what are the
tweets that Elon Musk has put out there
what are the ideas the thoughts that
Elon Musk has put out there that are so
controversial now I get defending free
speech is thought of as a controversial
uh idea in this very wacky world that we
live in but nothing he has put out has
been bigoted or hateful or censorious or
anything else he's trying to even the
playing field he's doing it quite well
so far that doesn't mean he'll always do
it well we shall see there are some
questions as I addressed yesterday with
this new CEO that he's hiring from NBC
Universal who definitely has a woke
streak in her so that is something to be
addressed and he has promised to address
it so that's let's just put that there
but as far as I know he hasn't been
saying anything really controversial in
in reality but the other thing is if he
was was woke if he was awoke leftist
like most of the CEOs are or at least
pretend to be he would never be getting
asked this question right so if he was
for chopping kids genitals off if he was
for teaching neo-racism in schools and
all of like the crazy nonsense right if
he was for all of that that wouldn't be
thought of as controversial and there
would be no need for a CNBC host to ask
him those things so the question the
nature of the question in and of itself
is somewhat ridiculous and shows you how
slanted everything is and actually it
shows you the the very thesis of why
Elon Musk got Twitter which is we have
to get out of this little box that cable
news Keeps Us in right with their sort
of Overton window on what we can talk
about and how we can talk about it he's
actually widening the uh the lane that
we can speak of things in and that is
pretty good so uh also the idea that uh
you know a guy they always talk about Fu
money you know the phrase Fu money like
you know when you have a certain amount
of money let's say 10 million bucks 20
million bucks he's got billions and
billions of dollars but when you have a
certain amount of money it's Fu money
meaning then you can go ahead and say
whatever you think and I always think
this is kind of funny because I I know a
lot of very very rich people including a
couple billionaires and what I have
found generally is that the Richer
people get the more they feel that they
have to lose so they start doing the
reverse of what Fu money might what you
might think Fu money might do to you
they actually stop saying things because
now they feel they have too many things
to worry about and everything else and
too many guns pointed at them and the
rest of it so the question really I
think for for Elon and what I think is
working for uh well certainly for me and
for you guys people that are trying to
fight for what is good it's like what I
let's put it this way what is the what's
driving it what is really driving him
well I think part of it is that the
whole machine has become so completely
ridiculous it is so obvious that our
opposition is either mind muddled or
communist or socialist or some
combination thereof or a whole bunch of
other things uh first let's this is this
is an oldie but a goodie it's a little
gratuitous but let's just remember uh
one of Joe Biden's greatest hits in the
last year or so
I'll need an effective strategy to
mobilize true and international effort
to pressure
okay and I don't know that that uh was
ever mobilized but it was one of the
things Joe Biden was up to but then of
course behind Joe Biden right and
obviously there's a long list of videos
we could have shown you of Joe Biden
shaking hands with nobody wandering off
uh you know having no idea where he's
going off stage and the Litany of things
the confusions not knowing people's
names being handed notes talking to the
Easter Bunny we could have done any of
those but that's just a little we just
there's a little bite of Joe Biden for
you but of course what uh sits right
behind Joe Biden is even scary it's
Kamala Harris you might remember this
one
and most recently they even want to
eliminate classes that teach quote
gender ideology
well so
what are we talking about here
classes that teach women's history
women's equality
the study of the fact that there are
still only 25 women in the United States
Senate in a body of 100.
he is just something else first off
gender ideology has nothing to do with
women's history women's history like say
American history or black history or
whatever history history the facts
behind history aren't just that they're
facts so no one's saying don't teach the
history of women in America the right to
vote the right to work
etc etc that is very different it has
absolutely nothing to do with gender
ideology and I would say she either
knows that but I don't know if she knows
that so she either knows it or doesn't
know it it's almost irrelevant at this
point but these are just not the best
and the brightest right Joe Biden not
the best and the brightest Kamala Harris
not the best and the brightest but
speaking of not the best and the
brightest we had a little debate we had
a debate this morning do we play a video
of John fetterman it is such low-hanging
fruit this thing is so ridiculous it is
so patently absurd that this man is a
senator that do we show you this now he
got out of he was in a home he was in
like Shady Pines or something he was a
little depressed a little depressed he
was in a home hasn't really done much
work finally they get him out there he's
the senator from Pennsylvania as you
know they're at a senate hearing and
here unedited unedited for you is about
90 seconds of John fetterman may God
have mercy on your soul
is is it staggering is it a staggering
responsible responsibility that the the
head of a bank could literally could
literally crash our economy
it's astonishing that's like if you have
I mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in
they guaranteed a guaranteed way to be
saved by again by no matter no matter if
I have by how you know so it's it's you
know isn't it appropriate that the those
kinds of this kind of control should be
more stricter
to prevent this kind of thing from going
or should we just go on and start
bailing and sailing whoever Bank
regardless of how however there's their
conduct is
you know I'll give you an example uh the
Republicans want to give a a work
requirement for snap you know for a a a
a hungry family has to to have these
this kind of penalties are these some
kinds of word working uh required
rubrics shouldn't you have a working
requirement after we sell your bank with
billions of your bank
because they see me weren't preoccupied
uh when then snap and their requirements
for works for Hungry people but not
about protecting the tax the tax papers
you know that will fail no matter
whatever does about a bank to crash it
all right honestly I don't know whether
to laugh or cry I really don't we all
kind of had the same reaction and we've
already watched it this morning it's
like first off this where he stops
several times the implication is Now
respond right so I wish they had had the
video on the person he's talking to as
well because how could you ever respond
to any of that right it's it's circular
it's confused it's muddled like you sort
of have a sense of what he's saying that
we shouldn't be bailing out Banks
because he wants money to go to other
programs snap programs but it's just
like do you think honestly does anyone
in this country honestly believe this
man should be a senator Dr Oz could have
been the senator and you might not like
Dr Oz for whatever reason you may not
think he was great maybe he didn't spend
enough time in Pennsylvania whatever it
is but Dr Oz would be up there speaking
in full sentences but this is what we're
up against a guy with dementia a man a
woman who is just not that bright to say
the least and then basically an
incapacitated vegetable that is what I
think Elon Musk is seeing it's what I'm
seeing it's what you're saying this is
not the best of the best why do we keep
losing to them I think there are reasons
for that there's algorithmic reasons
there's corporate reasons there's
probably philosophical reasons and and
religious reasons to it but I think we
can get over it but the sheer stupidity
and and
ugh it's not just stupidity it's it's
it's almost evil to some degree because
this is just not how it's supposed to be
but the sheer stupidity is not just
limited to our government it's the
entire machine and I think that's why
you should start being a little more
Fearless yourself they can't get all of
us so you may have seen this video so
this video is from uh about a month ago
this is a Miller Lite beer commercial
celebrating women's History Month by a
comedian named Alana Glazer but it's
been making the rounds over the last
couple days again now you this is you
could sort of put this to the backdrop
of what happened with Bud Light right
Bud Light gets sponsored by Dylan
Mulvaney who is a dude who dresses like
a woman Bud Light is now absolutely in
the tank and I don't think they're
coming back Anheuser-Busch is in a lot
of trouble well Miller Lite did their
own sort of version of the Bud Light
situation and only now is it kind of
picking up steam take a look a little
known fact women were among the very
first to brew beer ever from Mesopotamia
to the Middle Ages to colonial America
women were the ones doing the Brewing
centuries later how did the industry pay
homage to the founding mothers of beer
they put us in bikinis
wow
look at this
wild it's time beer made it up to women
so today Miller Lite is on a mission to
clean up not just their the whole beer
Industries
Miller Lite has been scouring the
internet for all this and buying it back
so that he can turn it into good shop
for women Brewers literally good how you
ask ladies take it away first we turn
the badge into compost now we feed
compost towards pushed out beautiful
fertilizer
that good helps Farmers grow quality
hops
which has been donated to women Brewers
to make their own really good but
there's definitely more out there
in your attic in the garage in your
parents basement send any you got
into Miller Lite and they'll turn that
into good too
oh so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear
foreign
[Music]
well first off Phoenix just goes she's
the reason misogyny exists okay that's
that's one personal opinion of Phoenix
the producer
um does that make anyone let's just put
aside all of the Just General nonsense
to it for just a second does that make
anyone want to drink Miller Light beer
do you think one man was watching that
and been like
um okay this makes me want to drink
Miller Light beer and do you think one
woman was watching it and was like all
right they're finally doing it my way
I'm gonna drink Miller Light beer Brock
just said he's never seen a woman drink
Miller like beer generally women don't
drink beer as much so if you're shifting
your whole Market towards trans women or
women women you're probably not doing
something great full disclosure I used
to do stand up way back when 20
something years ago with Anna she was a
perfectly fine comedian I kind of liked
her in a way we once got into a debate
though I liked Tim Allen she really
hated Tim Allen there was a big debate
we had about that one night but okay
sidebar uh anyway this desire
for for these companies to destroy
themselves
it just never ends so then because that
video was making the rounds then a
couple other things of Alana made the
rounds and again I don't really mean to
make this about her but I think it just
shows you the type of people that
succeed in the system right and what do
I always tell you about Stephen Colbert
he gives the machine what it wants uh
here's video of Alana on Colbert giving
the machine exactly what it wants she's
uh talking to him because he's a decent
white man
since we've been watching all this you
know
whatever real news and
news I have been thinking Stephen that
you are a really
um
model white man you're a a really I am
the picture in the dictionary next to a
white man I think they don't get much
wider than me you are the good version
of one because almost our president is
almost like the number one white guy
that you know in America because he's
the president but I'm also like also
Stephen colbertis you've just been
um revealing yourself to us over the
years in the way I've been watching
Strangers With Candy lately and you've
just been revealing yourself in this
sincere way
you know guys they're the racist and we
really just gotta like just like sit
with that and know it and accept it like
you're the good white man I get I get
she's trying to be funny like not really
accomplishing it I suppose she's trying
to be funny and then he just sits there
and okay Pat me on the head blah blah
blah but you're the good white man
because you do everything that the woke
left wants right you give the machine
everything it wants but she continued
with edgy comedy because on this she had
this show Broad City I've never seen it
uh but they they refuse to say the word
Trump on the show because it was edgy
comedy
you guys made a little bit of political
comedy news in the last couple of days
because what you're doing something
special this season with uh well with
that with our president what is it yes
we are bleeping
his last name
last name he gets enough air
and what you know it's in in the world
it would be better
you could actually say anything you
could say anything you want in that
moment you and that's where people would
know what you were saying you could say
you're saying Trump but you could say
anything you want right that's true okay
like all right you don't say his name
very edgy comedy fine now why am i
showing you all that because I wanted to
prove two things with all of these clips
first off they're not giving us the best
of the best out of the political
establishment right so you got by it and
you got Kamala you got fetterman you
guys get it you got AOC you got the rest
of this is this is just not the best of
the best and then culturally what are we
seeing on television with our comedians
well you've got this Glazer chick you've
got Colbert this is not the best of the
best and why do they keep showing us
these people uh it's because it's their
goal basically is to rot us out so we
will not know what is real what is good
we will not know facts we will not know
humor we will not know anything else and
it allows them to put enough chaos out
there that the lies just spread
endlessly but I am a believer that the
truth will always Prevail and there are
other people out there that believes
that believe that the truth will prevail
Elon Musk is one of them
um you know you do some tweets that seem
to be or at least give support to some
who would call others conspiracy
theories
well yes but I mean honestly you know
so many conspiracy theories uh have
turned out to be true
which ones well like the the 100 Biden
laptop that's true yeah yeah so uh you
know that that was a pretty big deal
there was Twitter and and and others
engaged in active suppression of
information that was relevant to the
public
um that's that's a that's a terrible
thing that happened that's electric
interference
okay so you see what's going on here
guys we live in this time with sort of
oh well not that word uh we live in a
time of uh not that bright politicians
and we live in a time of bad comedians
our cultural taste makers aren't being
honest with us our politicians aren't
being honest with us and then Along
Comes This Tech guy who's just trying to
clean it up a little bit and then you
see how the mainstream media reacts I'm
not even telling you that that
interviewer was so horrible like he
wasn't he wasn't like unbelievably
horrible uh but the idea that he's
questioning Elon because elon's just
trying to open up the books just trying
to go oh the government was working with
Twitter to censor people people have
been Shadow banned and everything else
and now we are finding out that more and
more of what we were told was definitely
true like Russia collusion all these
years yeah it was all complete nonsense
we've got some info here from the daily
wire special counsel John Durham who was
tasked by former Attorney General Bill
Barr to examine the propriety propriety
of of the FBI's investigation of
President Trump released a 320-page
report Monday that found that the FBI
had no evidence to support a
trump-russia scandal when it began its
investigation and found sobering
differences in how it approached the
Trump probe compared to other
politically sensitive investigations it
said the FBI immediately opened a full
investigation based on a brief note from
an Australian Diplomat recounting that
he had met with George Papadopoulos a
volunteer with the Trump campaign in
which he mentioned that Russia might
have information negative to Hillary
Clinton at the time the opening of
Crossfire hurricane the FBI did not
possess any intelligence showing that
anyone associated with the Trump
campaign was in contact with Russian
Intelligence Officers at any point
during the campaign the Durham report
said guys you really gotta understand I
know you get it right like I know you
get it but you've got to tell other
people
you have to tell everyone you have to
get it down Square stand on a rock and
scream Russia collusion all of it was
nonsense from the beginning there is far
more evidence that points to the Clinton
campaign and now even to Obama having
known about what they were trying to do
to Trump even before he took office and
now what's happening is because of this
report even the mainstream media which
which endlessly pushed these lies why
did I not push these eyes all these
years I've been on all these years since
before the Trump presidency why don't
you where is it that why is it am I such
a genius that I wasn't fooled by this or
had already peered behind the curtain
and realized that it was all nonsense
probably the way you did as well
and had there been evidence I would have
gladly talked about it like that's just
if you're a decent human being but these
people on mainstream media they pushed
the lives relentlessly and now they're
having to walk back a little bit here's
the one guy that people seem to think is
still decent on CNN Jake Tapper I'm not
so sure about the decent part but he's
uh trying to have like a little bit of
the Maya culpa here maybe
but president Trump appeared so
confident of what Durham would find he
openly uh pressured the special counsel
to release his findings before the 2020
election regardless the report is now
here it has dropped and it might not
have produced everything of what some
Republicans hoped for it is regardless
devastating to the FBI and to a degree
it does exonerate not to a degree it
does exonerate Donald Trump it
completely exonerates Donald Trump so
even in his Maya culpa even saying the
FBI really effed this one up he's still
you know he's still shaving off the top
a little bit and I don't know what you
do with someone like Jake because I saw
you when that when that clip that I just
showed you and that was going viral
yesterday people are like oh Jake Tapper
you see he gets what's going on and he's
not that terrible except if we would not
take you more than two seconds to find
roughly I don't know 500 billion clips
of Jake Tapper pushing Russia collusion
nonsense for years here's one from 2017.
I mean we could have picked any here's
just here's just an old throwback
we have some breaking news Now CNN has
learned new information about that
ongoing investigation into those
allegations raised in a collection of
memos created by a former British
intelligence agent at the time he made
the MMOs for political opponents of then
candidate Donald Trump Tim shudo and
Evan Perez have been working the story
and Jim let's start with you what
precisely have investigators learn well
Jake for the first time U.S
investigators say that they have
corroborated some of the communications
detailed in a 35-page dossier compiled
by a former British intelligence agent
CNN was first to report last month that
then president-elect Donald Trump and
President Barack Obama were briefed on
the existence of the memos prior to the
inauguration until now U.S officials
have said that none of the content or
allegations have been verified but now
multiple current and former U.S law
enforcement and intelligence officials
tell CNN that an intelligence intercepts
of foreign Nationals confirmed that some
of the conversations described in the
dossier took place between the same
individuals on the same days and from
the same locations as detailed in the
dossier we should be clear that CNN has
not confirmed the content of the calls
or whether any of the content relates to
then candidate Trump isn't it incredible
now watching that seven years later like
it was all a lie and even the way Tapper
kicks it off ongoing investigations into
allegations by a British spy it all
sounds like something without really
saying anything and then they bring on
Jim shudo and because he talks like a
newsman and we heard this from a British
spy and bro you start thinking it's real
and it was all absolute nonsense so I
actually this is an open-ended question
for you guys let's let's hit this in the
in the post game show on locals I want
to hear your thoughts on this like what
what do you do with a guy like Tapper
like to me all of these people should be
fired they should all be so shamed and
fired and everything else but like how
much leeway should there be on people
that lie about everything and then
eventually kind of get it right I don't
know that if you're in the media you
should have much leeway on that imagine
if I had just lied to you about a
gajillion things over these last six
years I'm pretty sure you would watch
something else I would recommend you
watch something else I'd probably find
another line of work to be in but these
people are absolutely Shameless and it's
not just obviously it's not just Russia
it's covid
it's absolutely everything so speaking
of guys that lie Adam's ship you
remember Adam Schiff congressman Adam
Schiff who I think is now running to be
senator from California because he's a
Democrat with Democrat privilege which
means if you screw everything up you get
to move up the ladder uh here's a little
compilation of him just lying everything
that you're about to see is a complete
lie it starts off with Chuck Todd and
then it's a Schiff lyapalooza enjoy
there's been no shortage of
Investigations into president Trump now
or soon to be underway they're looking
into the president's Tax Returns His
Inaugural Committee the Trump
organization Russian influence in the
campaign and a lot more at the center of
many of these investigations is going to
be the house intelligence committee and
at the head of that committee as it's
chairman Adam Schiff but we do know this
the Russians offered help the campaign
accepted help the Russians gave help and
the president made full use of that help
and that is pretty damning whether it's
simply Donald Trump reacting to the
question that's been raised about his
legitimacy because of the the taint over
the election but when people say there's
no collusion they must have a different
word for the kind of corrupt
coordination of effort between the Trump
campaign and the Russians we know that
the president has made probably over a
thousand false statements about the
Russia issues very clear that the Trump
campaign welcomed Russian helped built
it into their campaign plan never
reported it it made full use of it and
then lied about it Bob Mueller did not
find that there was no collusion in fact
in the first couple pages of report he
said we don't address that issue what we
found is we could not prove criminal
conspiracy Beyond A Reasonable Doubt the
president had just incited a mob that
attacked the capital and killed result
in the deaths of of five people
all right so that's
Endless Lies over the course of several
years he will not pay a price for it he
will still run for Senator he'll
probably be a senator from California
and that's how the thing will work but
we have to expose these people and again
you have to know it I have to know it
and then we have to convince more people
of it so that we can actually change
things because otherwise the lies they
will never stop no one ever pays the
price right the vaccines will work you
better take a vaccine no one gets fired
Russia collusion ah the election was
illegitimate when it was the guy that we
didn't like then when it was the guy we
did like you're not allowed to say
anything we've got to put an end to all
of this but it never stops and don't
worry guys I don't want to pick on
Schiff it's not just shift how about a
little Eric swalwell you remember Eric's
wall well he's the worst of the worst
the guy has been caught it is a known
fact that he slept with a Chinese spy
the way you know it's a fact is because
Kevin McCarthy house leader Kevin
McCarthy has said it publicly many times
and the media refuses to report on it
you would think think that if they knew
it was a lie they would be using it to
destroy Kevin McCarthy he's lying about
irks while sleeping with the Chinese spy
but they're ignoring it which means that
it's true here is swallow well talking
to Wolf Blitzer very serious newsman
Wolf Blitzer and telling him that
they're strong and clear evidence of
Russia collusion
in our investigation we saw strong
evidence of collusion the Republicans
now are choosing to bury it I don't know
what you call it when the Russians make
multiple approaches to members of the
Trump family the Trump organization the
Trump campaign to offer and preview dirt
on Hillary Clinton where the candidate
stands in front of a public crowd and
says Russia you'll be rewarded if you
hack her deleted emails and then once
Russia does it the campaign doesn't
report to law enforcement its prior
contacts with Russia they actually
amplify through social media the
candidate's own words what Russia hacked
I I think that is it that's clear
collusion but there's also evidence that
the public has not yet seen that we
think if we release our transcripts they
would also find us yeah well how about
you release those transcripts now now
that we know it's all BS so he's an
absolute liar and again slept with a
Chinese spy but now let me connect this
to something else that's happened in the
last couple weeks as you guys know
Tucker Carlson is no longer with Fox
News so probably the a guy who is the
most influential political talker in the
country right specifically political
talker political analyst in the country
was fired by the number one cable news
show uh he had Eric swalwell on back in
2017 so again this is six seven years
ago had Eric swalwell on and he was
telling him way back then that the Trump
Russia stuff was complete nonsense and
it makes you wonder so why did Tucker
get fired because he was getting a lot
of things right take a look at this
he is competing in energy with them in a
way Obama never tried why is he more
pro-russian than Obama was don't confuse
what he has to do because the public
sentiment is so high in Washington again
you give him too much credit you're
giving them too much credit giving him
credit I'm criticizing him I don't think
he should be doing any of that I'm just
saying this whole thing is insane that's
what I'm saying so and then you have all
the consciousness of consciousness of
guilt evidence right all of the lies
that have been told whether it was about
the June 9th meeting the Russian
adoption excuse and then moving it right
out what it was really about okay but so
that's that's consciousness of guilt a
lot of times the way someone Acts
after an investigation is launched can
tell you what they were doing I guess
I'm not you know what I'm not going to
avoidant maybe don't confuse don't
confuse evidence okay with the
conclusion there's more than enough
evidence to continue and find out how
close were these ties
remember guys six years ago Tucker
Carlson who's no longer with Fox News
was basically saying this was all Bs I
do a news show every day I never gave it
any Credence why is it that everyone in
mainstream media and all of the
political Elite and all the Dems fell
for it well I think you know the answer
right they just wanted to get rid of
trump and Truth be damned right like it
did not matter what the truth is we are
going to take these guys out but that
leads us to
something else that I'm always talking
about how we are living in very
different realities right now and even
people on the other side of that reality
are starting to understand the danger of
that now I would argue it's mostly their
fault they lied about so many things for
so long covid and Russia and very fine
people on both sides and you you guys
know what Brett Kavanaugh cereal rapist
Jesse Smollett was going to be hanged
that's been beaten with a Subway
sandwich or whatever the hell was going
on with him uh Kyle Rittenhouse
Covington kids like they lie and lie and
lie all the shootings they pick whether
it's a white supremacist even if it's a
Mexican woman all the stuff you got it
okay fine
what I'm realizing now is that even the
people on the other side of this who
have been the purveyors of the lies who
have been the ones pushing the machine
to lie more and more now they're
realizing that we are starting to have
an actual crisis in reality here is
Barack Obama just in the last couple
days he is now worried that we're going
to live in two very different worlds I
would argue it's largely because of him
and the entire machine that backs him
but suddenly he's starting to be
concerned about that take a look
I'm an optimistic man
but I find myself falling into this
space where I have concern about the
country that they will inherit right
once I'm gone
post-presidency what about this country
keeps you up at night
the thing that I'm most worried about is
the degree to which
we now have a divided conversation
in part because we have a divided media
right so
I'm much older than you Nate
you don't look it though that's what I
was fishing for
but when I was coming up you had three
TV stations yeah and people were getting
a similar sense of what is true and what
isn't what was real and what was not
today what I'm most concerned about is
the fact that because of the splintering
of the media we almost occupy different
realities if something happens in the
past everybody could say all right we
may disagree on how to solve it but at
least we all agree that yeah that's an
issue now people will say well that
didn't happen or I don't believe that
okay so first up I want to give the
devil his due here Obama is actually
just repeating something that I often
say right like we are depending on what
news you live in yeah you watch living
in very different worlds when he talks
about growing up ABC NBC CBS they had
Nightly News at 6 30 p.m and depending
on whether you like Tom Brokaw or Peter
Jennings you would decide uh which news
your cast you're going to watch because
they basically covered the exact same
stuff now we might argue you can argue
that that was pretty good for the
reasons that Obama's saying it that we
could we basically As Americans had this
had a certain Overton window which
allowed us to see certain things and
then we could argue about policy but our
basic reality was the same then of
course after just Network news then we
got cable news 24 hour news then we got
the internet and it's frayed in a
million different ways so I will give
him credit for saying that his concern
is right but it's he's only coming up
with this concern because I think
they're losing the narrative I think
he's realizing boy this is a problem now
uh because so many people are seeing we
have lied about everything and because
we have lied about everything people are
starting to tune out from us I think
Obama because I do think he's a control
freak to a degree and he and he has
definite socialist impulses I think he
would love if the state had the power to
control the media enough so that the
people would just understand the one
thing and it would be the one thing that
he wants but again
given the devil is due he is right we
are living in two different worlds I
would say one of those worlds is filled
with lies that is I just gave you the
long list of the laundry list of lies
right and one of those is filled with
the truth
and I would like to believe that we're a
little bit more on the side of the truth
here that Tucker has been a little bit
more on the side of the truth that
people like Elon Musk and Joe Rogan all
the people trying to siphon through all
of the BS and come out with some sense
of reality they're a little more on the
side of the truth rather than the people
who just swallowed the state line
believe the corporate press and then get
proven wrong on everything but never pay
the price on it so what do we do how do
we how do we let's say expand the truth
well we've got to build systems that
will do it we have to build systems that
will allow the truth to get out there
one of the drawbacks of having only ABC
NBC and CBS at 6 30 is that that slim
Overton window while it was good because
we could all sort of believe the same
things we don't know how much truth
couldn't get in right we don't know how
many things they had to ignore or what
they didn't want us to know about and
everything else so if we are a little
uh more Brave if we show a little more
ambition maybe we can actually innovate
maybe we could do things like I don't
know create a tech company like locals
that could then join up with Rumble to
defend Free Speech you know what
happened by the way this is just a
slight sidebar but you know a couple
months ago uh in France they wanted
Rumble to take down a couple videos and
they said if you don't take down these
Russian it was RT Russia Today related
videos we're going to take Rumble down
from your from the entire country and
Chris pavlovsky who's a friend of mine
and also the CEO of the company he said
we will not take down those videos and
if you want to take us off your entire
country go ahead and do so and that's
exactly what France did but the point is
we stood up for free speech what Elon is
doing right now with Twitter is standing
up for free speech and that was a hell
of a segue because I've got another
video right now of Elon Musk talking
about free speech and Twitter
let's talk about Free Speech a bit you
know you call yourself a free speech
absolutist you want Twitter and this is
aspirationally aspirationally you want
Twitter to be as truthful as possible
most accurate source of information
about the world
um so what does that mean for how you
police lies on the platform you
mentioned Community notes is that I
think Community yeah I mean I'd say so
my overall
kind of vision for Acts or Twitter is to
be a
cybernetic Collective mind for Humanity
this is going to sound quite esoteric in
sci-fi but
um so the if if you know in pursuit of
that objective you want to have uh
information move quickly have that
information be accurate and you want to
have error correction on that
information so you can think of
community notes as like an error
correction on information in the network
and the effective Community notes is
actually bigger than it would seem it's
bigger than the number of notes because
if somebody knows that they're going to
get noted they are less likely to say
something that is false because it's
embarrassing to get community noted okay
but and those and that applies even to
advertisers okay so there's something
interesting going on here first of all
first off if you're not on Twitter and
as I always say if you're not on Twitter
there's no reason to get on Twitter
although it is way more interesting now
than it was say a year ago but if you're
not on Twitter you don't know a
community you know it's our very briefly
Community notes is an account that they
created in essence to create crowdsource
truth so that if someone goes up there
and just blatantly lies about something
whether it's a politician a media person
a random account whatever it is just
absolutely blatantly lies about
something they crowdsource enough
information from enough users of Twitter
and then it puts a tag on that tweet
saying what the actual truth is and it
can and I think you can sort of Click
further and find out a little bit more
about the information etc etc now the
other part that he mentioned that's
really interesting is that once you have
something like that in place it actually
de facto encourages people not to lie as
much because people don't want to be hit
with this community notes warning it
makes you look illegitimate so that in
and of itself just having a system that
it's not a perfect system it absolutely
isn't a perfect system because you could
have a truth that a whole bunch of
people don't like and they could
overwhelm the system with lies so it's
not a perfect system but he's trying to
come up with something for our
Collective hive mind as he said it's
very sci-fi he's trying to do a little
something and and it seemingly is
working at the moment and that truth is
the biggest threat to the Liars that is
it right there guys so you have to build
systems that incentivize truth that's
what he's doing I think you personally
you got to tell the truth and you just
have to be Fearless in the face of a
president who can't speak English of a
vice president who's not that bright of
a senator from Pennsylvania who is
muddled Beyond imagination between
comedians who are liars and
ex-presidents who are now only getting
it because they're losing the narrative
if you follow that blueprint I think we
can overcome The Bravery deficit and
there was this guy a couple years ago
who did a video on prageru called The
Bravery deficit and we got a little clip
of it I like that guy who's that guy
because there's a mass Affliction
spreading throughout the Western world
it's called The Bravery deficit people
good people like you are afraid to say
what they think and there's Little
Wonder the understandable temptation is
to think that this politically correct
Madness will soon end just die out on
its own well it won't if you're one of
the people who believes that if you just
remain quiet that things will get better
well I hate to be the bearer of bad news
but you're a frog in a slowly Boiling
Pot and it doesn't end well for the Frog
so what can you do believe it or not the
solution is not that hard step one think
for yourself step two say it out loud be
better than those who would silence you
de-platform you and MOB you how
just stop being afraid
how my beard got less granted over the
years it's a modern Miracle we'll have
to look into that I want to thank you
people for watching the show today Brock
you're not having lunch because I'm
officially declaring this a 9-7 it was a
fine show I think it was ideologically
sound I think we debunked some lies I
think we told something true was there
any laughs today because the other on
Monday I forgot to add a couple laughs
and then yesterday we had a couple
laughs was there a laugh today there was
yeah
tomorrow will be funnier that's the plan
that's the plan we're gonna we're slowly
ramping up now that I'm back in studio
you know what I mean uh if you want to
join us for the post game show we'll be
there in about 42 seconds
reubenreport.locals.com we leave you
with a slightly edited video of Bill
Gates and Anthony fauci goodbye
and within 11 months have a vaccine you
know when I first thought I thought that
can't work
there is so much conspiracy theory they
were absolutely correct we have a
generation that's speaking out on this
topic yeah not easy uh but since it may
be necessary to avoid climate change we
shouldn't give up and it needs a level
of cooperation
the emergence of a new infection a brand
new disease killing almost everybody
[Music]